the Dumbo live-action trailer just
dropped with a gorgeous look at the
ninth wonder of the universe the world's
only flying elephant yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
breaking down the first teaser trailer
for Dumbo which is jam-packed with
Easter eggs and other intriguing details
you might have missed the trailer kicks
off with a cover of baby mine the
beautiful and iconic song that Dumbo's
mother sang to him while she was locked
up in solitary confinement the song
received an Oscar nomination for Best
Original Song in 1942 and for the
live-action version is sung by Norwegian
singer-songwriter Aurora the song is
part of a heartbreaking moment from the
original movie where Dumbo's mother
cradles the baby elephant in her trunk
as she sings a lullaby at the time mrs.
jumbo had been locked away after getting
angry when her son was tormented by some
boys she was branded and mad elephant
and there's a nod to that in the mad
elephant sign you can see behind Dumbo
in this image and just before that it
even looks like another elephant was
being carted away in a cage perhaps his
mother in the original Dumbo's mother is
still with him at the end so the trailer
for the live action movie could be
teasing something darker possibly akin
to Tim Burton's previous movies now in
the original film on the advice of the
crows Timothy Q Mouse employs a
psychological trick with a pretend magic
feather to give Dumbo the confidence
that he can fly the new movie tips its
hat to that moment when new character
Millie holds the feather up to Dumbo
telling him to show others what he can
do
indeed Millie's words to the young
elephant echo Timothy Q mouse's line
when Dumbo flies for the first time at
the circus at Sharpshooter Shawn by the
way the new film isn't going to be a
direct recreation of the original movie
in fact at CinemaCon Disney revealed
that while the original ends with the
elephant flying Tim Burton's film
actually takes that as a jumping off
point for Dumbo's newest story which
will be an expanded version of what
we're expecting which means that the
feather in this scene here is probably
more of a reminder to Dumbo what he can
already do rather than a mental trick to
get him to consciously fly for the first
time in front of an audience
I think Milly is going to play a key
role in the new movie in fact notice the
actual key she's wearing as a necklace
and she seems to be replacing the part
of Timothy Q Mouse's Dumbo's best friend
and confidant valise played by niko park
the daughter of actress Tandy Newton and
filmmaker ol Parker I love this image of
a pink elephant surrounded by bubbles
which is a lovely callback to the scene
in Disney's classic animation where
Dumbo and Timothy Q Mouse accidentally
got drunk on champagne and started
hallucinating pink and multicolored
elephants also notice that he's about to
be raised up on this platform here that
Dumbo is wearing a triangular shaped
headpiece with a D on it which very much
reminds me of the scene in the animated
movie where Dumbo carries a flag adorned
with the letter D as he's about to
launch himself into the air to form the
top of an elephant pyramid speaking of
pyramids the choreography and geometric
shapes in this scene here pay homage to
the extravagant musical numbers staged
by famed director and musical
choreographer Busby Berkeley which is
actually a hundred percent perfect for
Tim Burton's Dumbo because as well as
films such as 42nd Street Busby Berkeley
also choreographed Billy Roses jumbo
which just happens to be another movie
about a circus which featured an
elephant named jumbo and of course jumbo
jr. was Dumbo's real name in the
original animation
it looks like person is going to wow us
with plenty of fantastic visuals of
dreamland and I'm curious whether that
wonders of science attraction might be a
sly reference to the form of wonders of
life pavilion at epcot walt disney world
something it doesn't look like we'll see
adapted from the animation for the
storks which delivered the baby circus
animals including Dumbo himself theirs
are likely not to this by the flock of
birds which fly past the elephant's
enclosure which seems like a bit of a
message to the audience that we
shouldn't expect exactly the same movie
as the original because no these aren't
storks another thing I really don't
think we'll be seeing in this new film
are the animated crow characters as
they've been heavily criticized as
racist stereotypes of African Americans
they do of course sing the famous when I
see an elephant fly song and I wonder if
we'll see an updated version of that in
the movie as I mentioned before the new
movie is a sort of continuation or
expansion of the original film from 1941
by the end of which Dumbo is famous with
aircraft even being made in his likeness
during World War two in terms of the
timeline of the live-action film that
set just after the Second World War
notice that Colin Farrell's character
halt who's a veteran is missing
armed presumably an injury from the war
and he and his two children discovered
Dumbo for the first time hiding
underneath a pile of straw at Disney
CinemaCon presentation it was revealed
that Danny DeVito runs a traveling
circus that's struggling to keep going
DeVito's character is called max Medici
and he's trying to use Dumbo's fame as
an amazing flying elephant to bring
people to the circus
however Medici also has to reprimand his
employees for their mistreatment of
Dumbo and it seems this might be wide
Dumbo's hiding away here I think the
scene where Holtz and his kids
discovered Dumbo might also be a little
tribute to a mrs. jumbo
unwrapped her new delivery from the
storks and the animated feature and
revealed the adorable car for the first
time and talking of Dumbo and his mother
I also like how the weather vane at the
beginning of the trailer has a young
elephant holding on to the tail of an
older elephant just like we saw Dumbo do
with his mother many times in the
original film now how excited are you
for the new Dumbo movie and what other
cool details or Easter eggs did you spot
in the trailer let's keep the
conversation going in the comments below
I've got new Incredibles 2 videos coming
later this week so hit the bell to get
notified of those if you enjoyed this
video a thumbs up is always appreciated
and you can tap here to watch more of my
Disney and trailer breakdowns thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers